There's this moment during the Cuban Missile Crisis that's so incredible, it doesn't sound real. But we have confirmed this with people who were there. Victor Gilinsky wrote about this for the Bulletin of the Atomic Scientists.
在古巴导弹危机期间，有这样一个时刻，它是如此令人难以置信，听起来都不真实。但我们已经从当时在场的人那里证实了这一点。《原子科学家公报》的维克多·吉林斯基对此进行了撰文。
He said, basically, nuclear war seemed so imminent that the underground headquarters of the Strategic Air Command in Nebraska went into lock down. Nobody was allowed to enter or leave. He said the General in charge told the staff he expected an order to launch nuclear missiles any moment, and also expected that they would all die from a Soviet counterattack.
他说，当时核战争似乎迫在眉睫，内布拉斯加州战略空军司令部的地下指挥部进入了封锁状态。任何人都不得进出。他说，负责的将军告诉工作人员，他随时准备接到发射核导弹的命令，也预料到他们所有人都会死于苏联的反击。
And everybody was allowed to make one phone call home to their family. But in that call, they were not allowed to say why they were calling. What do you say in that situation?
每个人都被允许给家人打一个电话。但在那个电话里，他们不被允许说出为什么要打电话。在这种情况下，你能说什么呢？
Gilinsky writes, "The conversations were about scraped kids' knees and sick dogs. It was a scene straight out of Dr. Strangelove ." And of course, right? What can words do when you're staring death in the face?
吉林斯基写道：“谈话内容都是关于孩子擦伤的膝盖和生病的狗。那场景简直就像电影《奇爱博士》里的情节。”当然，不是吗？当你面对死亡时，言语又能起到什么作用呢？
Well, today on our program, we have two stories where ordinary people rise to this exact task. They see death standing there, and they open their mouths. And truly amazing things happen.
好吧，今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述两个普通人应对这一任务的故事。他们看见死亡就在那里，于是他们开口了。真正令人惊叹的事情发生了。
We have two stories for you today. And to say anything else about these stories, I think, would be a spoiler. Also, I want to give every possible second to these stories. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And let's just get to it with the first act of our show.
今天我们为您准备了两个故事。我认为，关于这些故事再说任何话都会是一种剧透。另外，我想把每一秒钟都留给这些故事。这里是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。让我们直接进入节目的第一幕吧。
So remember that tsunami that hit Japan five years ago, March 2011? Giant black waves more than 30-feet tall hit Japan.
还记得五年前，也就是 2011 年 3 月袭击日本的那场海啸吗？高达 30 多英尺的巨大黑色海浪袭击了日本。
[JAPANESE PEOPLE YELLING]
[日本人的叫喊声]
A guy in a little town called Otsuchi shot this video. You can hear him yelling.
一个叫大槌町的小镇上的人拍下了这段视频。你可以听到他在大喊。
[JAPANESE PEOPLE YELLING]
[日本人的叫喊声]
All the houses are washing away.
所有的房子都被冲走了。
[JAPANESE PEOPLE YELLING]
[日本人的叫喊声]
Otsuchi had been there for 100 years. In 30 minutes, it was gone-- almost totally flattened.
大槌町已经存在 100 年了。在 30 分钟内，它消失了——几乎被完全夷为平地。
The tsunami and the earthquake that went with it killed six times more people than died in 9/11-- over 19,000 people. Another 2,500 are still missing. And in the aftermath, of course, families struggled to figure out how they were going to move forward without the people they loved.
那场海啸以及随之而来的地震造成的死亡人数是 9·11 事件的六倍——超过 19,000 人。另有 2,500 人至今下落不明。当然，在余波中，家庭都在努力寻找如何带着对逝者的爱继续前行。
And in that town of Otsuchi, it lead to this new-- I don't know, ritual is not exactly the right word for this. But it's something close to that-- this thing that people invented to stay connected to the dead. One of our producers, Miki Meek, has family in Japan.
在大槌町，这导致了一种新的——我不知道，“仪式”这个词并不完全准确。但这很接近——这是人们发明出来与死者保持联系的东西。我们的制作人之一，美纪·米克，她在日本有家人。
And she grew up going back and forth between there and here. And she watched this documentary about this thing people are doing Otsuchi, on the Japanese news channel, NHK, and got permission for us to play you some excerpts. Here's Miki.
她从小就在日本和这里之间往返。她在日本新闻频道 NHK 上看到了关于人们在大槌町所做的事情的纪录片，并获得了播放片段的许可。这是美纪。
Of all the areas in Japan affected by that tsunami, Otsuchi has one of the highest numbers of missing people-- 421. Today, it's still partly in ruins and partly a construction site, as they try to rebuild the town on higher ground. But a year before that tsunami happened, this guy named Itaru Sasaki-- he was already dealing with a loss.
在日本所有受海啸影响的地区中，大槌町的失踪人数最多——421 人。今天，那里仍有一部分是废墟，一部分是建筑工地，因为他们试图在高地上重建城镇。但在那场海啸发生的前一年，一个叫佐佐木格的人——他已经在应对失去亲人的痛苦了。
His cousin had just died. And Itaru was having a hard time figuring out how to talk about it. So he did something pretty ingenious.
他的表亲刚去世。佐佐木格很难找到表达哀悼的方式。所以他做了一件非常有创意的事情。
He went out and bought an old-fashioned phone booth and stuck it in his garden. It looks like an old English-style one. It's square and painted white, and has these glass window panes.
他出去买了一个老式的电话亭，把它放在他的花园里。它看起来像那种旧式的英国电话亭。它是方形的，漆成白色，有玻璃窗格。
Inside is a black rotary phone, resting on a wood shelf. This phone connected to nowhere. It didn't work at all.
里面是一部黑色的转盘电话，放在木架上。这台电话没有连接任何地方。它根本不能使用。
But that didn't matter to Itaru. He just needed a place where he felt like he could talk to his cousin, a place where he could air out his grief. And so putting an old phone booth in his garden, which sits on this little windy hill overlooking the Pacific Ocean, it felt like a perfect solution.
但这对佐佐木格来说并不重要。他只是需要一个地方，让他觉得可以和他的表亲交谈，一个可以宣泄悲伤的地方。所以，在俯瞰太平洋的一个多风小山丘上的花园里放一个旧电话亭，这感觉像是一个完美的解决方案。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
He's saying, because my thoughts could not be relayed over a regular phone line, I wanted them to be carried on the wind.
他说，因为我的思念无法通过普通的电话线传递，我想让它们随风而去。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
So I named it the wind telephone-- kaze no denwa. The idea of keeping up a relationship with the dead is not such a strange one in Japan. The line between our world and their world is thin.
所以我把它命名为“风之电话”——Kaze no denwa。在日本，与死者保持联系的想法并不奇怪。我们世界与他们世界之间的界限很薄。
Lots of families keep a Buddhist altar for their dead relatives in the living room. My uncle has one for our family. There are photos on a little platform. And every day, he leaves fresh fruit and rice for them, lights incense, and rings a bell. It's a way to stay in touch, to let them know that they're still a big part of our family.
许多家庭在客厅里为死去的亲人供奉佛龛。我的叔叔为我们的家庭设了一个。小平台上放着照片。每天，他都会为他们留下新鲜的水果和米饭，点上香，敲响铃铛。这是一种保持联系的方式，让他们知道他们仍然是我们家庭的重要组成部分。
So after the tsunami and earthquake happened, word got out about Itaru's special wind telephone-- that he was using it as another way to stay connected to the dead. Soon, people started showing up randomly on his property, and walking right into the phone booth. This has been going on for five years now. Itaru estimates that thousands of people from all over Japan have come to use his phone.
所以在海啸和地震发生后，佐佐木格的特殊“风之电话”的消息传开了——他正在利用它作为与死者保持联系的另一种方式。很快，人们开始随机出现在他的房产上，径直走进电话亭。这种情况已经持续五年了。佐佐木格估计，来自日本各地的数千人已经来使用他的电话了。
A TV station asked Itaru, and the people who come to use his phone, if they could videotape their calls from a distance, and put an audio recorder in the phone booth. They wanted to get a sense of how people are still grieving. I watched their documentary after the fifth anniversary of the tsunami back in March. That whole week, all of the news programs in Japan were airing memorial programs.
一家电视台询问佐佐木格以及来使用他电话的人，是否可以从远处拍摄他们的通话，并在电话亭里放置录音机。他们想了解人们是如何继续悲伤的。我在三月份海啸五周年纪念日之后观看了他们的纪录片。那一整周，日本所有的电视新闻节目都在播放纪念节目。
But I found the calls in this particular program remarkable and moving, for just how simple they were. One woman from Otsuchi, named Sachiko Okawa, showed up one afternoon. She's 71-years-old, and lost her husband in the tsunami.
但我发现这个节目中的通话非常引人注目且令人动容，仅仅是因为它们是多么简单。一位来自大槌町名叫大川幸子的女士，一个下午出现在那里。她今年 71 岁，在海啸中失去了丈夫。
She regularly brings her two young grandsons to the phone booth. And you can tell, by how casually they talk to him on the phone. They squish into the phone booth with their grandma, wearing matching blue-and-black-striped shirts.
她经常带着两个年幼的孙子来到电话亭。你可以从他们随意地在电话里跟他说话的方式看出来。他们穿着蓝色和黑色条纹的亲子装，挤在电话亭里和他们的奶奶在一起。
Sachiko starts the call by picking up the receiver and saying hello.
幸子通过拿起话筒说“喂”开始通话。
Moshi moshi.
喂，喂。
Moshi, moshi.
Her oldest grandson quickly jumps in.
她的大孙子很快插话。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Hi grandpa.
爷爷好。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
How are you?
你好吗？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I'll be in fourth grade next semester. Wasn't that fast?
我下学期就要上四年级了。是不是很快？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Daina, my younger brother, he'll be in second grade next year. Then Sachiko corrects him. She says, no, Daina will be in second grade this year, not next.
大奈，我的弟弟，明年要上二年级了。然后幸子纠正了他。她说，不，大奈今年上二年级，不是明年。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Yeah, this year.
对，今年。
A lot of calls were just like this, straightforward updates about life. The kind of a quick highlights reel you might give to any family member you were catching up with on the phone. The boy, he then tells his grandpa--
很多通话都像这样，是关于生活的直接更新。就像你与任何你在电话中叙旧的家庭成员可能会聊到的快速摘要。那个男孩，他接着告诉他的爷爷——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Grandma's fine too.
奶奶也很好。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I'm giving the phone to Daina now.
我现在把电话给大奈。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Daina, his little brother, grabs the phone.
大奈，他的弟弟，接过了电话。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Grandpa, I finished all my homework. Sachiko urges him to keep talking.
爷爷，我的作业全写完了。幸子催促他继续说。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
He says, everyone is doing fine. Then he hangs up. They all say goodbye.
他说，大家都很好。然后他挂了电话。他们都说了再见。
Bye, Bye.
拜拜。
[HANGS UP PHONE]
[挂断电话]
As they're walking out of the booth, Daina says--
当他们走出亭子时，大奈说——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Maybe Grandpa will say  he heard us.
也许爷爷会说他听到了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
In another call, a woman in a puffy winter jacket with a fur-lined hood shows up at the booth by herself. Her name is Kikue Hirano, and she's 66. She used to live in Otsuchi. But she moved away after she lost her house and her husband in the tsunami.
在另一个通话中，一位穿着带毛领兜帽的蓬松冬装外套的女士独自出现在亭子里。她的名字叫平野菊惠，今年 66 岁。她过去住在大槌町。但在海啸中失去了房子和丈夫后，她搬走了。
Her husband was a deep-sea fisherman. His name was Miyoji, and they used to talk and drink sake together at night. Now Kikue lives alone, about 50 miles away.
她的丈夫是一名深海渔民。他的名字叫美代治，他们过去常常在晚上一起交谈和喝清酒。现在菊惠独自居住在约 50 英里外的地方。
But sometimes Kikue finds herself driving back to Otsuchi, into this booth. I watched her do this thing that a lot of callers seem to do. You hear Kikue actually dialing the rotary phone--
但有时菊惠发现自己会开车回到大槌町，走进这个亭子。我看着她做很多打电话的人似乎都会做的事情。你听到菊惠在拨打转盘电话——
OK.
好的。
--saying some numbers to herself.
——自言自语说出一些数字。
[KIKUE HUMS]
[菊惠哼唱]
4, 2, 5, 7, 4, 4. She's dialing the phone number for her old house in Otsuchi, the last place she knew to reach her husband. Then Kikue just stands in the booth in silence, holding the phone to her ear.
4，2，5，7，4，4。她在拨打她在大槌町老家的电话号码，那是她知道能联系到丈夫的最后一个地方。然后菊惠就静静地站在亭子里，把电话贴在耳边。
Sometimes she fidgets around and tilts her head up, and concentrates on the ceiling, the same way I do when I want to cry but I'm trying hard not to. It doesn't work. Kikue brushes some tears off her face. Eventually, she hangs up.
有时她会烦躁地动来动去，头向上仰，集中注意力看着天花板，就像我想要哭但又拼命忍住时一样。没用。菊惠擦去脸上的泪水。最终，她挂了电话。
She lingers in the booth a little longer, hands clasped together in front of her, staring at the phone booth floor. She walks out. One pattern that the owner of the phone booth, Itaru, has noticed over the years is that more men than women come to use it. Not surprisingly, this is not a demographic that's known for sharing their feelings, especially the older farmers. They already have a reputation for not talking much.
她在亭子里多逗留了一会儿，双手交握在身前，盯着电话亭的地板。她走了出来。电话亭的主人佐佐木格多年来注意到的一种模式是，男性比女性更常来使用它。不出所料，这并不是一个以分享情感而闻名的群体，尤其是那些老农民。他们已经有了不怎么说话的名声。
In one of the phone calls recorded in winter, a man with gray hair and a little towel hanging around his neck walks into the garden. This kind of towel is part of the uniform of Japanese farmers. They use them to wipe away sweat and clean their hands.
在冬天录下的一通电话中，一位灰头发、脖子上挂着一条小毛巾的男子走进了花园。这种毛巾是日本农民制服的一部分。他们用它擦汗和擦手。
This man opens the telephone booth door. And under his breath, you hear him say, huh, so this is the wind telephone? This appears to be his very first visit to the phone booth.
这个男人打开了电话亭的门。压低声音，你听到他说，呵，这就是风之电话？这似乎是他第一次来电话亭。
He lost his oldest son in the tsunami. His son's name was Nobuyuki. He also lost his house, and had to move into temporary housing with his wife.
他在海啸中失去了长子。他儿子的名字叫信之。他还失去了房子，不得不和妻子住进临时住所。
And recently, she got sick and also passed away. He calls her okaasan. It means "mom" in Japanese. It's what everyone in the family calls the female head of the house, even the husband. It's a very intimate, loving term.
最近，她也生病去世了。他称呼她为“妈妈”（okaasan）。这是日语中“妈妈”的意思。这是家里每个人对女性家长的称呼，连丈夫也一样。这是一个非常亲密、充满爱意的称呼。
[ROTARY PHONE DIALS]
[转盘拨号]
Moshi, moshi?
喂，喂？
Hello?
喂？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Nobuyuki?
信之？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Is mom with you?
妈妈和你在一起吗？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Sorry to ask this, but take care of her, and your grandma and grandpa too.
抱歉这么问，但照顾好她，还有你的爷爷奶奶。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Mom?
妈妈？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I'll come again, OK?
我还会再来的，好吗？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Mom, I'll be back.
妈妈，我会回来的。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Bye.
再见。
[HANGS UP PHONE]
[挂断电话]
[DOOR OPENS, CLOSES]
[门打开，关闭]
He uses the towel around his neck to wipe his eyes.
他用脖子上的毛巾擦了擦眼睛。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
One of the things that makes these calls so poignant to me is all the understated ways that people are actually saying, I love you, and I miss you. I'd never say something so direct like that in Japanese. It's just not done.
这些通话让我如此感动的其中一点是，人们用所有含蓄的方式实际上在说：我爱你，我想你。我永远不会用日语说出那样直接的话。那是不会做的。
I've only seen people say it in the soap operas. [JAPANESE]. Even saying that right now, it feels weird. I've never said that to my mom or my grandparents.
我只见过人们在肥皂剧中说。[日语]。即使现在说出来，也感觉很奇怪。我从来没有对我妈妈或爷爷奶奶说过。
[DOOR OPENS, CLOSES]
[门打开，关闭]
[ROTARY PHONE DIALING]
[转盘拨号]
Take this call. It's winter. The phone booth is surrounded by snow.
接这个电话。是冬天。电话亭被雪包围着。
Moshi, moshi?
喂，喂？
Hello?
喂？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Mom?
妈妈？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Where are you? He's an older man wearing a baseball cap. He also calls his wife "mom." His wife, daughter, and mother, they all went missing in the tsunami.
你在哪儿？他是一位戴着棒球帽的老人。他也叫他的妻子“妈妈”。他的妻子、女儿和母亲都在海啸中失踪了。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
It's so cold. But you're not getting cold, are you?
好冷啊。但你不冷，对吧？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Are grandma and our daughter, Miyuki, with you too?
奶奶和我们的女儿美雪也和你在一起吗？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Come back soon.
快回来吧。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Be found soon. Everyone is waiting for you.
快被找到吧。大家都等着你。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
OK?
好吗？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I'll build the house in the same place.
我会在同一个地方建房子。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Eat something-- anything.
吃点东西——什么都行。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Just be alive, somewhere, anywhere.
只要活着，在某处，哪里都行。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I'm so lonely.
我好孤独。
[DOOR OPENS]
[门打开]
[WINDCHIMES]
[风铃]
[DOOR CLOSES]
[门关闭]
He never says I love you directly. Real feelings are communicated through small gestures, especially ones of concern. Like when he asked his wife, are you staying warm?
他从不直接说我爱你。真实的感情是通过微小的姿态传达的，尤其是那些关心的姿态。就像当他问他的妻子，你暖和吗？
Are you eating? And then promising, I'll build a house for us. These are total heartfelt declarations of love.
你吃东西了吗？然后承诺，我会为我们盖一所房子。这些都是全心全意的爱之宣言。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
For other men, the phone booth is a place where they can finally say their complicated feelings out loud. They can voice their regrets. Anyone who's had someone close to them die knows this feeling.
对于其他男人来说，电话亭是一个他们最终可以大声说出复杂感受的地方。他们可以表达他们的遗憾。任何经历过亲人去世的人都知道这种感觉。
Like, I've kept having the same one-way conversation with my dad in my head, ever since he passed away last year. I just keep telling him all the situations where I wish I had been kinder, more patient. One call I watched was from a young father, with rectangle glasses and a long black jacket.
比如，自从我爸爸去年去世后，我一直在脑海里和他进行同样的单向对话。我只是不断地告诉他所有我希望自己当初能更仁慈、更有耐心的情况。我观看的一通通话来自一位年轻的父亲，戴着矩形眼镜，穿着长长的黑色外套。
He lost his family-- both parents, his wife-- her name was Mine-- and one-year-old son, named Issei.
他失去了他的家庭——双亲、他的妻子——她的名字叫美奈——以及一岁的儿子，名叫一成。
[ROTARY PHONE DIALING]
[转盘拨号]
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Dad?
爸爸？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Mom?
妈妈？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Mine?
美奈？
Issei?
一成？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
It's already been five years since the disaster.
灾难已经过去五年了。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
If this voice reaches you, please listen.
如果这个声音传到你那里，请听一听。
(CRYING) [JAPANESE]
(哭泣) [日语]
Sometimes I don't know what I'm living for.
有时候我不知道我为什么活着。
(CRYING) Issei, [JAPANESE]
(哭泣) 一成，[日语]
Issei, please let me hear you call me Papa.
一成，请让我听听你叫我爸爸。
(CRYING) Papa, [JAPANESE]
(哭泣) 爸爸，[日语]
Even though I built a new house--
即使我盖了新房子——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Dad? Mom?
爸爸？妈妈？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Mine  and Issei.
美奈和一成。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
--without all of you, it's meaningless.
——没有你们所有人，这一切都毫无意义。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I want to hear your reply, but I can't hear anything.
我想听到你的回复，但我什么也听不到。
[EXHALE] [SNIFFLE]
[呼气] [吸鼻涕]
[PHONE CLICKS UPON HANG UP]
[挂断电话的点击声]
He hangs up the phone, takes off his glasses, and covers his eyes with his hands.
他挂了电话，摘下眼镜，用双手捂住眼睛。
(WHISPERING) [JAPANESE]
(低语) [日语]
I'm sorry.
对不起。
(WHISPERING) [JAPANESE]
(低语) [日语]
I'm so sorry I couldn't save you.
对不起，我没能救你们。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
[DOOR OPENS]
[门打开]
[DOOR CLOSES]
[门关闭]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
There's a couple phrases I heard callers tell the dead, again and again. Shinpai shina, don't worry about us. And ganbatteiru, which basically means, I'm doing my very best. I'm enduring.
我听到拨打者反复告诉死者的有几句话。“Shinpai shina”，不用担心我们。“Ganbatteiru”，基本上意思是，我正在尽我最大的努力。我在忍受。
In Japan, ganbatteiru-- it's a catchall slogan for slogging through life's many challenges, no matter how tiny or big. From trying to pass a test at school, to grieving, you hear it all the time for everything. In the phone booth, ganbatteiru, and shinpai shina-- these are key phrases to reassure the dead that the living, the people left behind, they're doing OK, even if they're not.
在日本，“Ganbatteiru”——这是一个应对生活许多挑战的万能口号，无论多么微小或宏大。从试图通过学校考试，到悲伤，你一直都能听到它。在电话亭里，“Ganbatteiru”和“Shinpai shina”——这些是关键短语，用来安慰死者说，活着的人，留下来的人，他们过得还好，即使他们并不好。
People don't want to worry or burden their loved ones, even dead loved ones. Because most Japanese are Buddhist, and generally believe that when someone dies, they're not suddenly relieved of all their earthly concerns. They're not automatically in heaven, happy and carefree. Many people believe that if the dead see a family member suffering, they can't let go of their earthly life. They hesitate to cross to the other side, and end up stuck in a no-man's land.
人们不想让心爱的人担心或增加负担，即使是已经死去的亲人。因为大多数日本人是佛教徒，普遍认为当某人去世时，他们并不会突然摆脱所有世俗的牵挂。他们不会自动进入天堂，快乐且无忧无虑。许多人相信，如果死者看到家庭成员受苦，他们就无法放下世俗生活。他们会犹豫是否要跨越到另一边，最终被困在“无主之地”。
I heard these reassurances in a call from a 15-year-old kid named Ren Kozaki, to his dad. He arrived at the phone booth after spending four hours on public transportation by himself. Ren lives in a city much farther north that wasn't affected as much by the tsunami.
我听到一位名叫小崎莲的 15 岁孩子在给爸爸的通话中听到了这些安慰。他在独自乘坐了四个小时的公共交通后到达了电话亭。莲住在一个更北边的城市，那里受海啸的影响没那么大。
But his dad was a truck driver who drove all over Japan. And in a last-minute schedule change, he got sent on a route that took him along the coast when the tsunami hit. He's been missing ever since. Ren went into the phone booth wearing a red backpack.
但他的爸爸是一名卡车司机，开车走遍全日本。在最后一分钟的日程变更中，他被派往沿海路线，当时海啸发生了。从那以后他一直失踪。莲背着红色背包走进了电话亭。
[DOOR OPENS]
[门打开]
And what he does in his call-- you hear him signaling to his dad that it's OK. He should keep moving on into the after world.
他在电话里做的事情——你听到他向爸爸示意一切都好。他应该继续前往来世。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Dad?
爸爸？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
The four of us are doing fine.
我们四个都很好。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
We're ganbatteiru.
我们都在 Ganbatteiru。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
You don't need to worry about us. Shinpai shina.
你不必担心我们。Shinpai shina。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Dad, are you doing OK?
爸爸，你过得还好吗？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I do have one question I want to ask you.
我有一个问题想问你。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Why did you die? Why did it have to be you, dad?
你为什么死了？为什么非得是你呢，爸爸？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Why just me?
为什么偏偏是我？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I've always wondered--
我一直在想——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Why am I the only one who is different from everyone else?
为什么我是唯一一个与众不同的人？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Anyways, please be found quickly.
不管怎样，请快点被找到。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Where are you now?
你现在在哪儿？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
They never found anything of you.
他们从没找到关于你的任何东西。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I wanted to talk with you again.
我想再和你谈谈。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
[SNIFFLES]
[吸鼻涕]
Ren left the booth. In late February, he came back with his entire family-- his mom, younger brother, and sister. They all drove down to Otsuchi together. And when they got to the phone booth, at first, they kind of awkwardly hung out in front of it. So to break the ice, Ren walks in and places the first call to their dad. He tells him--
莲离开了亭子。二月下旬，他带着全家人回来了——他的妈妈、弟弟和妹妹。他们一起开车下到大槌町。当他们到达电话亭时，起初，他们有些尴尬地站在亭子前面。为了打破僵局，莲走了进去，给他们的爸爸打了第一个电话。他告诉他——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I brought everyone with me today.
我今天带大家一起来了。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Bye. When Ren walks out, his family laughs. They say--
再见。当莲走出来时，他的家人笑了。他们说——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
--that was so fast. Ren shoots back--
——好快啊。莲反驳道——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
It was just a quick report to Dad, that I brought everyone with me today. Next up are Ren's little brother and sister, who are 12 and 14 years old.
那只是给爸爸的一个快速报告，我今天带大家一起来了。接下来是莲的弟弟和妹妹，他们分别是 12 岁和 14 岁。
[DOOR OPENS, CLOSES]
[门打开，关闭]
They go into the booth together. And the sister is talking and laughing nervously.
他们一起走进亭子。妹妹在紧张地说话和笑。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
What am I supposed to say? What should I tell them?
我该说什么？我该告诉他们什么？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Wait, wait, don't leave me alone in here.
等等，等等，别把我一个人留在这里。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
The sister picks up the phone. And let me just say, the mom told the film crew that this is a girl who has not said a single word about her dad to anyone since he went missing five years ago. So she picks up the phone and starts to cry.
妹妹拿起了电话。让我先说，妈妈告诉摄制组，这是一个从五年前爸爸失踪后，就再也没有对任何人说起过爸爸的一个字的女孩。所以她拿起电话开始哭。
[SOBBING] [JAPANESE]
[啜泣] [日语]
She asks her brother again, when should I talk to him about? Her little brother's name is Riku, and he tells her--
她又问弟弟，我该和他谈些什么？弟弟的名字叫陆，他告诉她——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Say what you wanted to tell him.
说你想告诉他的事。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
She says--
她说——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Are you trying to make me laugh, Riku? Riku says--
你是在想逗我笑吗，陆？陆说——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
No, I'm not.
不，我没有。
Then she finally starts talking to her dad. The conversation is all over the place, and she's crying so hard, she can barely talk.
然后她终于开始和爸爸说话了。谈话内容很杂乱，她哭得很厉害，几乎说不出话来。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Dad, I'm so sorry I always used to say you were stinky.
爸爸，对不起，我总是说你很臭。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
What happen to your promise to buy me a violin?
你答应买给我的小提琴怎么了？
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Now I'll have to buy one myself.
现在我得自己买一把了。
Her little brother, who sticks close to her, he encourages her to keep going. He says--
紧挨着她的弟弟鼓励她继续说。他说——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
What else? So she tells her dad--
还有什么？所以她告诉爸爸——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I started tennis in junior high school. I'm not in the top eight.
我在初中开始打网球了。我没进前八名。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I want to be in the top eight our last tournament.
我希望在我们的最后一场锦标赛中进入前八。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Please cheer for me.
请为我加油。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I got hooked on this boy band, the Johnnys, when I was in my first year of junior high. I'm still hooked.
我在初一时迷上了这个叫 Johnnys 的男子组合。我还在迷。
They both say--
他们都说——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
--goodbye. They come out of the booth together.
——再见。他们一起走出了亭子。
Now it's their mom's turn. Her kids tell her, itterashai.
现在轮到妈妈了。她的孩子们对她说，“Itterashai”。
Itterashai.
Itterashai。
Have a good trip.
旅途愉快。
Itterashai.
Itterashai。
Good luck. Ren, the oldest, he bows and waves to her. She walks in, picks up the phone, and lets out a big sigh.
祝你好运。最年长的莲鞠躬并向她挥手。她走了进去，拿起电话，长叹了一口气。
[SIGH]
[叹气]
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Where should I start?
我该从哪儿开始呢？
[SIGH]
[叹气]
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
I feel like you're still alive-- somewhere.
我觉得你还活着——在某个地方。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
We had so many things we wanted to do together.
我们有那么多想一起做的事情。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Over the phone, we always said to each other, are you alive? Yes, I'm alive.
在电话里，我们总是问对方，你还活着吗？是的，我还活着。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
It was our password between the two of us, wasn't it?
那是我们俩之间的密码，不是吗？
(CRYING) [JAPANESE]
(哭泣) [日语]
I can't ask you that anymore.
我不能再问你那个了。
[SIGH]
[叹气]
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Come back.
回来吧。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
We, all four of us together, we will be waiting.
我们，我们四个人在一起，会一直等着。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Bye.
再见。
[SIGH]
[叹气]
[HANGS UP PHONE]
[挂断电话]
[DOOR OPENS]
[门打开]
After she comes out, the family lingers outside the phone booth for a while.
她走出来后，一家人在电话亭外逗留了一会儿。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
This was literally the first time they'd all talked about their dad together, since the tsunami happened five years ago. The youngest, Riku-- he sat quietly on a bench, with his head in his hands. The night before his dad disappeared, they went to a public bath together. His mom and older siblings tell him--
这实际上是自五年前海啸发生以来，他们全家第一次一起谈论爸爸。最小的陆——他静静地坐在长椅上，头埋在手里。爸爸失踪的前一天晚上，他们一起去洗了公共澡堂。妈妈和哥哥姐姐告诉他——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
Riku, you don't need to keep your feelings in. Go ahead and cry when you want to. Ren, the oldest, gently teases him. He says--
陆，你不必把感情憋在心里。想哭的时候就哭吧。最年长的莲轻轻地逗他。他说——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
See? He can't stop crying. Mom says yeah, but--
你看？他停不下来哭。妈妈说，是啊，但是——
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
--he held back until now.
——他直到现在都在忍着。
[JAPANESE]
[日语]
It's OK, because you held back. You endured until now.
没关系，因为你忍住了。你忍到了现在。
The sister then hands Riku her handkerchief.
妹妹随后递给陆她的手帕。
The mom says her kids, we were all about to fall apart. We were so broken. We didn't think we could make it through. And maybe that's why we never talked about dad until now. But talking to him on the phone today, it changed something.
妈妈说她的孩子们，我们都快崩溃了。我们破碎不堪。我们以为熬不过去。也许这就是为什么我们直到现在才谈论爸爸。但今天在电话里和他交谈，改变了一些事情。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our program. Thanks to NHK Sendai, who recorded all this, and shared it with us. Coming up, two brothers in their 80s have a last chance to talk to each other before they die. And neither wants to take it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
美纪·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。感谢录制这一切并与我们分享的 NHK 仙台放送局。接下来，两位 80 多岁的兄弟在去世前有最后一次交谈的机会。但谁都不想抓住它。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共电台的节目继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "One Last Thing Before I Go," stories that are about-- well, they're about what power do words have in the face of death? We've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“临走前的一件事”，故事是关于——嗯，它们是关于言语在面对死亡时有什么力量？我们已经到了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Uncle's Keeper. So in the first act of our program, people kind of defied death by making small talk-- and some talk that was not so small-- with their dead relatives.
第二幕，叔叔的守护者。在节目的第一幕中，人们通过与已故亲人进行小谈——以及一些并非小谈的谈话——从而战胜了死亡。
In this act, somebody wants to do something very similar-- make a connection that seemed impossible between people. Except in this story, all the relatives are alive, which you'd think would make it super easy. This story comes from Jonathan Goldstein.
在这一幕中，有人想要做非常相似的事情——在人与人之间建立看似不可能的联系。只是在这个故事里，所有的亲戚都还活着，你可能会认为这会让事情变得超级容易。这个故事来自乔纳森·戈德斯坦。
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Dad?
嘿，爸？
Hi, Jonny.
嘿，乔尼。
Hey, how you doing?
嘿，你还好吗？
Good, you?
挺好，你呢？
Good, good. Gut Yontif.
挺好，挺好。“Gut Yontif”（祝节日快乐）。
Shana tova.
“Shana tova”（新年快乐）。
Chag Sameach.
“Chag Sameach”（节日快乐）。
Chag Sameach。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
What's that mean?
那是什么意思？
I'm not sure.
我不确定。
Oh, oh.
哦，哦。
This is my father, Buzz. I'm calling him at his home in Montreal. And the reason we're talking crazy talk is because it's Yom Kippur, the Jewish Day of Atonement, which seems as good a day as any to talk with him about forgiveness.
这是我的父亲，巴兹。我打电话给他位于蒙特利尔的家。我们说这些疯话的原因是因为今天是赎罪日，犹太人的赎罪日，这似乎是与他讨论宽恕的好日子。
So I wanted to--
所以我想——
Yes.
是的。
I wanted to ask you something. And I just wanted to gauge your interest.
我想问你件事。我只是想衡量一下你的兴趣。
Yeah.
嗯。
How-- how would you feel about paying your brother Sheldon a visit?
你——你觉得去拜访你兄弟谢尔顿怎么样？
I have no feelings about it. I'm not really interested.
我对此没有任何感觉。我真的不感兴趣。
You're not?
你不感兴趣？
No.
不。
My father, Buzz, is 80. And his brother, Sheldon, his only sibling, is 85. And for the past 40 years, they've pretty much been on the outs.
我的父亲巴兹今年 80 岁。而他的兄弟谢尔顿，他唯一的亲兄弟，今年 85 岁。在过去的 40 年里，他们基本上处于断交状态。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
My father lives in Montreal, and Sheldon lives in Florida. And the last time they saw each other, over 20 years ago, was at their mother's funeral, where they had a fight over the details of the arrangements. Since then, they've hardly spoken.
我父亲住在蒙特利尔，谢尔顿住在佛罗里达。他们最后一次见面是在 20 多年前，是在他们母亲的葬礼上，当时他们为了安排的细节吵了一架。从那以后，他们几乎没说过话。
It worries me, because there's not a lot of time left. And I don't want my father to have regrets. And my father has a profound capacity for regret. My mother gave up trying to reunite them years ago, after many attempts. So I know that if I don't push him, no one else will.
这让我担心，因为剩下的时间不多了。我不希望我父亲留下遗憾。而我父亲有极大的后悔能力。在多次尝试后，我母亲几年前就放弃了让他们团聚。所以我知道，如果我不推他一把，没人会。
I'm not surprised that you're not jumping at the idea. But I'm a little surprised--
你不愿意接受这个想法，我并不感到惊讶。但我有点惊讶——
No.
不。
-- that you're as against the idea.
——你居然如此反对这个想法。
Yeah, time's passed. He hasn't shown much interest. So I'm respecting that, and I leave him alone.
是啊，时间过去了。他没表现出什么兴趣。所以我尊重这一点，我就不打扰他了。
What he did do, was he called you on your 80th birthday, not so long ago.
他确实做了一件事，不久前在你 80 岁生日时给你打了电话。
Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。
And you felt good about that.
你对那件事感觉很好。
Yeah, because I called him on his 80th birthday.
是的，因为我在他 80 岁生日时给他打了电话。
This kind of tit-for-tat accounting is what always gets in the way.
这种锱铢必较的清算总是障碍所在。
You know what it is at this point, with him? I'll tell you what it is. I don't think it's even anger. He's past anger, and he's past any feelings of animosity. He's past that. He just doesn't care.
你知道他在这一点上是怎么想的吗？我告诉你是什么。我觉得那甚至不是愤怒。他已经过了愤怒阶段，也过了任何敌意阶段。他过了那个阶段。他只是不在乎。
Yeah.
嗯。
You know, that's apathy. I mean, sometimes-- at least hate or love, they're emotions. Apathy is nothing.
你知道，那是冷漠。我是说，有时候——至少恨或爱，它们都是情感。冷漠什么都不是。
Yeah.
嗯。
But you know what? Jonny, as a child, even when I was 10, when I was 9 and 8, I was crazy about him. We had a great-- you know, I loved him. He was the older brother. He was-- hello?
但你知道吗？乔尼，作为一个孩子，甚至当我 10 岁、9 岁、8 岁时，我对他很着迷。我们有过一段很棒的——你知道，我爱他。他是哥哥。他是——喂？
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm listening.
对，对，对，我在听。
You know, I just looked up to him. And he had all the friends. Sometimes he'd take me along with him. And he was [AUDIO OUT]. [INAUDIBLE]. Somebody tried-- is somebody to call here, binging me here?
你知道，我一直很崇拜他。他有很多朋友。有时他会带上我。他当时是 [音频输出]。[听不清]。有人试图——是有人打电话到这儿来吗？
The most complicated question, the one I keep coming back to, is how did the bad blood begin? And there are many versions. An ill-fated trip to Montreal, where Sheldon felt slighted about having to stay in my father's basement. An ill-fated trip to New York, where my father felt slighted about having to stay in Sheldon's attic.
最复杂的问题，我不断回到的问题是，这些不和是怎么开始的？版本有很多。一次不顺利的蒙特利尔之旅，谢尔顿觉得被冷落，因为不得不待在我父亲的地下室里。一次不顺利的纽约之旅，我父亲觉得被冷落，因为不得不待在谢尔顿的阁楼里。
Rude words spoken to each other's wives. In one version of the story, Sheldon's refusal to bring a table to my bris almost resulted in my being circumcised on an ironing board. But in the version being told today, my father was asked by Sheldon to pay more than his fair share for their mother's funeral.
对彼此妻子说了无礼的话。在故事的一个版本中，谢尔顿拒绝带一张桌子去我的割礼仪式，差点导致我在熨衣板上接受手术。但在今天讲述的版本中，谢尔顿要求我父亲为他们母亲的葬礼支付超过他合理份额的钱。
And I said, you're always working some kind of an angle. So he got furious. He got furious. He started screaming into the phone, go to hell. Drop dead, bah, bah, bah. He was-- that was how that ended.
我说，你总是在搞什么名堂。于是他大发雷霆。他大发雷霆。他开始对着电话尖叫，去死吧。死吧，巴，巴，巴。他当时是——事情就是这样结束的。
But I feel he's the kind of guy, that he has angles like that, you know? He has angles. I always felt I was on the up-and-up with him, and he wasn't with me.
但我感觉到他是那种人，他总是玩那样的手段，你知道吗？他有手段。我一直觉得我在他面前是诚实的，而他对我不是。
If you got a stronger sense that he was interested in seeing you, then would you--
如果你有更强烈的感觉他有兴趣见你，那你——
Yes. Yes.
会吗？是的。
You would be more inclined to see him?
你会更倾向于见他？
I wouldn't stay at his house though, that's out of the question.
不过我不会住在他的房子里，那是没可能的。
OK, quick sidebar. Anytime I've ever raised the prospect of visiting Sheldon, no matter how hypothetical the scenario, my father always makes a point of insisting how no matter what, he would not stay in Sheldon's house-- even if he was invited to. Which, I should point out, he never is.
好的，快速侧记。每当我提出拜访谢尔顿的前景时，无论场景多么假设，我父亲总是坚持说无论如何他都不会住在谢尔顿家里——即使他被邀请。我应该指出，他从来没被邀请过。
I wouldn't stay at his house.
我不会住在他的房子里。
How come you-- [LAUGHS]
为什么你—— [笑声]
I wouldn't stay there. I mean, it's not my thing.
我不会住在那儿。我是说，那不是我的事。
How come you always bring that up?
为什么你总是提起那个？
Because I don't feel comfortable.
因为我不觉得舒服。
Normally, when someone goes to visit someone that they haven't seen in decades, they'll stay at a hotel, you know? [LAUGHS]
通常，当一个人去拜访几十年没见的人时，他们会住在酒店，你知道吗？ [笑声]
I would stay at a motel or somewhere near his place.
我会住在汽车旅馆或他家附近的地方。
[LAUGHS] A motel. Yeah, no, we'd get a place with an ice machine and-- you know.
[笑声] 汽车旅馆。对，不，我们会找一个有制冰机的地方，还有——你知道。
Why, you're interested in making a trip?
怎么，你有兴趣去旅行吗？
I'm interested-- [SIGHS] Do you think that there's anything to be gained in seeing him?
我有兴趣—— [叹气] 你认为见他有什么收获吗？
Hmm, I guess there's something. You share your common experience, and you talk about the old days. There are things that only he and I can remember. You know?
嗯，我想有一些。你们分享共同的经历，谈论过去。有些事情只有他和我知道。你知道吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
What you could do is, you could call him.
你可以做的是，你可以打电话给他。
Yeah.
嗯。
And see what his attitude is. You know? It depends on how you feel, what kind of reception you get.
看看他的态度是什么。你知道吗？这取决于你的感觉，取决于你得到什么样的回应。
Yeah, I mean I would be happy to do that. My concern is that--
嗯，我的意思是我会很高兴去做。我担心的是——
I like your initial suggestion, that you call and feel him out. See what he's like.
我喜欢你最初的建议，你打电话去试探他。看看他怎么样。
OK, I didn't suggest that, but-- you-- [LAUGHS] you suggested that.
好的，我没建议那个，但——你—— [笑声] 你建议了那个。
Yeah, I like that. Because you'll give me an honest reaction.
对，我喜欢那样。因为你会给我一个诚实的反应。
I'm happy to do it. But, I mean, what are you looking for? What do you want to hear from him?
我很乐意去做。但是，我是说，你在寻找什么？你想从他那里听到什么？
I miss my brother, I would like to see him.
我想念我的兄弟，我想见他。
OK.
好的。
That's all.
就是这样。
OK.
好的。
You understand? And you come back on me with an honest evaluation.
你明白吗？你回来给我一个诚实的评估。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Sheldon?
谢尔顿？
Yes, speaking.
是的，我是。
Hi.
你好。
That was quite a shock, getting your phone call. You said, Jon, and my hearing is not that great.
接到你的电话真是太令人震惊了。你说，乔，我的听力不太好。
OK.
好的。
And when I heard the first message, I'm saying, who the heck is that? I don't know anybody by that name.
当我听到第一条留言时，我说，那到底是谁？我不认识那个名字的人。
Sheldon now lives outside of Fort Lauderdale. But my few memories of him are from when he lived in upstate New York. I remember he lived in a trailer.
谢尔顿现在住在劳德代尔堡外面。但我对他的一些记忆是他住在纽约上州的时候。我记得他住在拖车里。
I remember that he worked at a local prison, that he smoked cigars, that he looked a little like my father, but was hunched, like the world was weighing down on him. And he always wore this expression on his face that seemed to say, you got to be kidding me.
我记得他在当地监狱工作，他抽雪茄，他看起来有点像我父亲，但背部佝偻，好像世界压得他喘不过气来。他脸上总是带着那种表情，好像在说，你在开玩笑吧。
You're keeping OK? You're keeping occupied?
你还好吗？你过得充实吗？
Yeah, I read a lot. I go to the gym. I go shopping. You know, here and there, little things here and there.
是的，我读很多书。我去健身房。我去购物。你知道，这里一点，那里一点，点点滴滴。
So how often do you go to the gym?
那你多久去一次健身房？
Three times a week.
一周三次。
My father also goes to the gym. That's a part of his routine also. He was happy to hear from you on his 80th birthday.
我父亲也去健身房。这也是他习惯的一部分。他很高兴在你 80 岁生日时收到你的电话。
Yeah, well, he didn't call me on my 85th though.
是啊，但他没在我 85 岁生日时打给我。
Tit, meet tat.
礼尚往来。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
To be honest with you, in the last few years, I've been a loner.
老实说，过去几年我一直是个独行侠。
Uh huh.
嗯哼。
You would basically almost call me a recluse. I don't socialize with many people. And I really don't give a damn what anybody thinks.
你基本上几乎可以叫我隐士。我不和很多人交往。我真的不在乎别人怎么想。
Yeah.
嗯。
And contrary to popular belief, I like being alone, by myself. I get along with myself very well.
与大众的看法相反，我喜欢独自一人，自己一个人。我和自己相处得很好。
Yeah.
嗯。
Look, I don't want to be rude or anything, but I want to go have my lunch.
看，我不想无礼或什么的，但我想去吃午饭了。
Oh, yeah, yeah, that's fine.
哦，对，对，没关系。
Yeah.
是的。
It's fine. Sheldon, I appreciate your talking to me. And you would be amenable to spending some time?
没关系。谢尔顿，我感激你和我说话。你会愿意花点时间吗？
Why not? We are brothers. I mean, we're not close or anything. But you know, we're not going to have a chance to see each other much in the future.
为什么不呢？我们是兄弟。我是说，我们不亲密或者什么的。但你知道，我们未来没什么机会见面了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Yeah. Is that anything that you think about?
是啊。你考虑过那个吗？
Not much, no.
不多，没有。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Press where to, then type. Do you have an address?
按哪儿，然后输入。你有地址吗？
Yeah, I do.
是的，我有。
My dad and I meet up at the Fort Lauderdale airport. I flew from New York, and my dad from Montreal. My father's all dressed up, wearing a faux suede sports jacket that I've never seen him in. We grab our airport rental and prepare for the two-hour drive to Sheldon. In the 90-degree heat, it's immediately made clear that faux suede might not have been the best fashion choice.
我和我爸在劳德代尔堡机场汇合。我从纽约飞来，我爸从蒙特利尔飞来。我父亲穿得整整齐齐，穿着一件我从未见过的仿麂皮运动夹克。我们拿了机场租车，准备开始去谢尔顿家的两小时车程。在 90 度的酷热中，立刻明显感觉到仿麂皮可能不是最好的时尚选择。
It's like we're on a safari here.
这就像我们在进行狩猎旅行。
On the road to Sheldon's, my father will experience a spectrum of feelings. As we first set out, there's excitement.
在去谢尔顿路上的路上，我父亲会体验各种感觉。当我们刚出发时，那是兴奋。
My brother was funny in a lot of ways. I could laugh. We're going to have laughs with him. He's a very funny man.
我兄弟在很多方面很有趣。我会笑。我们会和他一起笑。他是一个非常风趣的人。
A half an hour in, and there's bitterness.
过了半小时，有了苦涩。
We invited him to your bar mitzvah. And he returned a very cold card. Sorry, we will not be attending. It was so mean. You know what I mean? Even the writing.
我们邀请他参加你的成年礼。他寄回了一张非常冷淡的卡片。对不起，我们将不会参加。太刻薄了。你知道我的意思吗？连写字都是。
An hour in, and how was Buzz feeling?
过了一个小时，巴兹感觉如何？
I'm relaxed.
我很放松。
Oh, good.
哦，好。
Kind of old to get anxious, you know what I mean?
太老了，没必要焦虑，你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
A half an hour to Sheldon's.
距离谢尔顿家还有半小时。
A little bit apprehensive now.
现在有点不安。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Yeah.
是啊。
10 minutes to Sheldon's, and Buzz is feeling--
距离谢尔顿家还有 10 分钟，巴兹感觉——
I'm all right.
我没事。
Yeah?
是吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah? You feeling a little--
是吗？你感觉有点——
Oh, it's going to be strange.
哦，这会很奇怪。
Yeah.
是啊。
It's going to be very strange. I mean, the man is a stranger to me now. And yet, he's my brother. You understand? It's a very strange feeling.
这会非常奇怪。我是说，那个人现在对我来说是个陌生人。然而，他是我的兄弟。你明白吗？这是一种非常奇怪的感觉。
Yeah.
是啊。
I wonder if he's getting nervous?
我想知道他是否在紧张？
Maybe.
也许。
Cause he's waiting for us, right?
因为他在等我们，对吧？
Yeah.
是啊。
Sheldon lives in the corner house on a quiet suburban street.
谢尔顿住在一个安静的郊区街道的拐角房子里。
Ring the bell.
按门铃。
I guess. Is this his door?
我猜。这是他的门吗？
I'll double check. Oh, here he is.
我再确认一下。哦，他在这儿。
Hi!
嗨！
Hello.
你好。
Hey!
嘿！
There's an [INAUDIBLE]
有个 [听不清]
It's good to see you.
见到你很高兴。
And this is Jonathan?
这是乔纳森？
Good to see--
很高兴见——
Nice to meet you. Come in.
很高兴见到你。进来吧。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Lately I've become a monk-- me and my pussycat.
最近我成了个僧侣——我和我的小猫。
Oh, you got a cat.
哦，你有只猫。
Oh, come here. What?
哦，来这儿。什么？
[CAT MEOWS]
[猫叫声]
After all the years and the worry and the dread, things seem to be going swimmingly. We sit down at Sheldon's kitchen table, and my father gets right into it.
经过了这么多年的担心和恐惧，事情似乎进展得很顺利。我们坐在谢尔顿的厨房桌旁，我父亲直接进入了正题。
Now there's things I want to know. You said that Rainy died?
现在有些事情我想知道。你说瑞尼死了？
Yeah, she died.
是的，她死了。
She did die.
她确实死了。
The dead are a good place to begin. As a subject, they're easily agreed upon, and not likely to spark a fight.
死者是一个很好的起点。作为话题，他们很容易达成一致，不太可能引发争吵。
Yankel died.
扬克尔死了。
Yankel died? He was the youngest brother.
扬克尔死了？他是最小的兄弟。
Oh, he died long ago.
哦，他很久以前就死了。
He died, eh? Oh, you know who died?
他死了，啊？哦，你知道谁死了吗？
Who?
谁？
Hoffman.
霍夫曼。
Hoffman? A real prick. [LAUGHS]
霍夫曼？一个真正的混蛋。 [笑声]
Yeah, I didn't know him that well.
是啊，我不太了解他。
What a prick.
真是个混蛋。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
Kanish. [INAUDIBLE]
卡尼什。[听不清]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉声音]
Oh, that's shocking.
哦，那太令人震惊了。
Yeah, he was fat.
是啊，他很胖。
He was fat. Redhead.
他很胖。红头发。
Redhead, right. Yeah.
红头发，对吧。是啊。
Kanish. Yeah, remember Johnny? Johnny was a sex maniac.
卡尼什。是啊，记得乔尼吗？乔尼是个性狂。
Johnny-- oh, he would [BLEEP] a dog on the street. If he saw the dog, he'd try to [BLEEP] the dog. [LAUGHS] Can I get you guys a cold beer?
乔尼——哦，他会 [消音] 街上的狗。如果他看到狗，他会尝试 [消音] 那只狗。 [笑声] 我能给你们拿杯凉啤酒吗？
I'd like a beer.
我想喝啤酒。
Yeah, sure.
是啊，当然。
How about you?
你呢？
I'll have a beer. Thank you.
我也要杯啤酒。谢谢。
Even though they're in their 80s, Sheldon and Buzz still possess voices and temperaments suited to shouting out Brooklyn tenement windows. While my voice--
尽管他们已经 80 多岁了，谢尔顿和巴兹仍然拥有适合在布鲁克林公寓窗户大声叫喊的声音和脾气。而我的声音——
(VOICE CRACKS) Yeah, sure, I'll have a beer--
(声音沙哑) 是啊，当然，我要杯啤酒——
Is best suited to asking a waitress if there will be a sharing charge.
最适合问女服务员是否会收取分享费。
I defined--
我定义了——
Oh, whoa.
哦，哇。
[THUD]
[沉重的声音]
[BLEEP] forgot about that. Sorry.
[消音] 忘了那个了。抱歉。
Case in point-- this is Sheldon accidentally swiping a portable microphone receiver off the kitchen table, and me trying to smooth things over.
举个例子——这是谢尔顿不小心把一个便携式麦克风接收器从厨房桌子上扫掉，而我试图圆场。
Take this off, will you? It's annoying.
把它拿走，好吗？很烦人。
Here, just put it in your pocket there.
来，把它放在你口袋里。
Just take it off, would you please? Thank you. Thank you.
就把它拿走，好吗？谢谢。谢谢。
All right.
好的。
Over the next two days, my testes will flee like frightened cockroaches, upward, ascending to heights not seen since the bar mitzvah that Sheldon was not attending. While it's fun watching them reminisce, I'd say, that about 80% of my uncle Sheldon's stories about the good old days are filthy enough to make them virtually unbroadcastable. But here's one-- specially selected, and beeped for your delicate ears.
在接下来的两天里，我的睾丸会像受惊的蟑螂一样逃跑，向上，上升到谢尔顿没参加的那次成年礼以来未曾有过的高度。虽然看着他们叙旧很有趣，但我会说，我叔叔谢尔顿关于美好旧时光的故事中，约有 80% 是肮脏得几乎无法广播的。但这里有一个——特别挑选，并为你的娇嫩耳朵进行了消音处理。
Wally Rosen. Wonder whatever became of him. He was a bum. Me and Wally Rosen were joining the weightlifting club. So you had to be tested for a rupture. I remember he put his hand [BLEEP]. I started laughing so hard, I [BLEEP] right in his [BLEEP]. [LAUGHS] Ay yay yay.
沃利·罗森。不知道他后来怎么样了。他是个流浪汉。我和沃利·罗森要加入举重俱乐部。所以你必须接受疝气测试。我记得他把手放进 [消音]。我开始大笑，笑得我 [消音] 在他的 [消音] 里。[笑声] 哎呀呀。
Over the years, I've seen my father in the role of husband, uncle, and grandfather. But I've never really seen him in the role of younger brother. How odd to see it now, at 80. He sits beside Sheldon, with this expression I've never seen on his face. It's wide-eyed, sweet, and deferential. But as the day wears on, Sheldon and Buzz begin to squabble over their memories, fighting over every little detail.
多年来，我看到我父亲扮演丈夫、叔叔和祖父的角色。但我从未真正看过他扮演弟弟的角色。现在 80 岁了，看起来真奇怪。他坐在谢尔顿旁边，脸上带着我从未见过的表情。它是睁大的、甜美的、谦卑的。但随着时间流逝，谢尔顿和巴兹开始为他们的记忆争吵，为每一个小细节争斗。
Remember the hullabaloo we had with hair dyer, that heavy-set girl?
还记得我们和那个染发师，那个胖姑娘闹的骚动吗？
She was a manicurist.
她是修指甲的。
She was a hair dyer.
她是染发师。
Manicurist.
修指甲的。
No, she was a hair dyer. Here's what happened. She went over to Irving's--
不，她是染发师。事情是这样的。她去了欧文家——
They even argue over the death of their grandmother.
他们甚至为他们祖母的死争吵。
I found her body.
是我发现了她的尸体。
I did.
是我。
I opened the door. No.
我打开门。不。
I did.
是我。
No, my mother was across the street, at [INAUDIBLE].
不，我妈妈在街对面，在 [听不清] 那里。
I remember walking in--
我记得走进去——
I walked in on her.
我走进她房间。
And I knew she was dead, soon as I saw her.
而且我看到她时，我就知道她死了。
I never saw a dead body in my life, but I knew she was dead. Sure.
我这辈子没见过尸体，但我知道她死了。当然。
So wait, so you found her, or you found her?
等等，所以是你发现她，还是你发现她？
I remember looking in on her room to see how she was doing. She was awfully quiet. [INTERPOSING VOICES]
我记得去看她的房间看看她怎么样。她太安静了。[交叉声音]
[INAUDIBLE]. I found her, but let him take the credit.
[听不清]。是我发现了她，但让他领功吧。
No, I'm not. [LAUGHS] Some credit.
不，我没有。 [笑声] 领功。
The whole afternoon is like this. Every subject, even their dead grandmother, somehow becomes fodder for another pissing match. They're burning up all this time with small talk, when what they need is some big talk. In particular, they need to address a story that I know holds a great deal of meaning for my father. It took place in 1939, on the day their mother left them. I've only ever heard the story from my father, never from Sheldon.
整个下午都是这样。每个话题，甚至他们死去的祖母，不知何故都成了又一场争强好胜的 fodder。他们把所有这些时间都花在小谈上，而他们需要的是大谈。特别是，他们需要解决一个我知道对我父亲有重大意义的故事。它发生在 1939 年，他们母亲离开他们的那天。我只从我父亲那里听过这个故事，从未从谢尔顿那里听过。
I wanted to ask what you remember. What your perspective--
我想问你记得什么。你的观点是——
Well, I remember that time was when Pop was smacking her around, and she ran out in the hall. And her slip--
嗯，我记得那段时间是老爸在打她，她跑进大厅。她的衬裙——
Fighting in the hall.
在大厅打架。
And he was smacking her around.
他在打她。
Yeah, smacking her around.
是啊，在打她。
She ran out.
她跑了出去。
So what happened the next morning?
那么第二天早上发生了什么？
The next morning?
第二天早上？
Yeah. Looked in her closet. Her clothes were gone. She left.
对。往她衣柜里看了看。她的衣服没了。她走了。
Ah.
啊。
What happened after this, in my father's telling, is that his mother returned soon after she left, with a policeman in tow.
这之后发生了什么，在我父亲的讲述中，是他母亲离开后不久就回来了，还带着一名警察。
And they came back to try to get you. They wanted you to come back with them.
他们回来想带你走。他们想让你跟他们一起回去。
And where were you?
那你当时在哪儿？
I was there, but they were trying to drag you out of the house. [LAUGHS]
我在那里，但他们想把你从房子里拖出去。[笑声]
They weren't trying to grab you out?
他们不是想把你抢出去？
No, no, no. I guess they want my father and grandmother.
不，不，不。我猜他们想要我父亲和祖母。
This is the point of the story for my father. It proves, once and for all, how his mother loved Sheldon more than she loved him. Sheldon didn't move out with her. And after a year, their mother returned. And together, Buzz and Sheldon grew up under the same roof, in the same bedroom, often sleeping under the same blankets, each knowing who the mother had chosen, and each having to do their best to carry on and live life with the burden of that knowledge.
这就是我父亲讲述的这个故事的核心。它证明了一劳永逸，他的母亲爱谢尔顿胜过爱他。谢尔顿没有跟她搬走。一年后，他们的母亲回来了。巴兹和谢尔顿一起在同一个屋檐下长大，在同一个卧室，经常睡在同一条毯子下，每个人都知道母亲选了谁，每个人都必须尽力背负着那份知识的重担继续前行。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
A couple times during the day, I ask them why they haven't spoken in so long. And they both insist, maybe out of embarrassment, that they do talk, just not often. But it isn't true. In fact, my father learned of Sheldon's wife's death many years after the fact-- and then, only from me.
在这一天中，我问了他们几次为什么这么久没说话。他们都坚持说，也许出于尴尬，他们确实谈过，只是不常谈。但这不对。事实上，我父亲在事后多年才知道谢尔顿妻子的死讯——而且还是从我这里得知的。
Sheldon's daughter got in touch through Facebook, and we made a phone date, where she caught me up on her life and Sheldon's. And a few nights later, while over at my parents' for dinner, I told my father of his sister-in-law's death. There was a terrible look that fell across his face. One of sadness, but something else too, maybe shock over just how far he and Sheldon had drifted.
谢尔顿的女儿通过 Facebook 与我联系，我们约了通话，她让我了解了她的生活和谢尔顿的生活。几天后，在父母家吃晚饭时，我告诉我父亲他弟媳去世的消息。他脸上露出了一种可怕的表情。一种悲伤，但还有别的，也许是对他与谢尔顿已经疏远到这种程度的震惊。
I found out about Judy-- about her death.
我发现了关于朱迪——关于她的死。
Who?
谁？
Your wife.
你的妻子。
I didn't know about it, either until you told me.
我不知道那件事，直到你告诉我。
Yeah.
是啊。
Didn't I tell you?
我没告诉你吗？
No.
没有。
You didn't know about it? No?
你不知道那件事？不？
We didn't know.
我们不知道。
Hmm?
嗯？
We didn't know.
我们不知道。
She was sick about two years there, Judy.
她病了大约两年，朱迪。
[SIGH] Too bad.
[叹气] 太糟糕了。
Well, when she got the diagnosis, she was already stage IV. What did I know about cancer? I didn't. The surgeon-- so I says, well, doctor, how did the surgery go? Oh, he said, it went very well. But the cancer's in her liver now. [INAUDIBLE].
好吧，当她拿到诊断结果时，已经是第四期了。我对癌症了解什么？我不了解。外科医生——所以我说，好吧，医生，手术怎么样？哦，他说，进行得很好。但癌症现在在她的肝脏里。[听不清]。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉声音]
Oh, it spread.
哦，扩散了。
I said, it's in her liver? I said, what?
我说，在她的肝脏里？我说，什么？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[RESTAURANT CHATTER]
[餐馆嘈杂声]
You know where I usually eat, when I come here by myself? By the bar. They've got a waitress there who always waits on me, and she takes good care of me.
你知道我一个人来这儿时通常在哪儿吃吗？吧台边。那里有个女服务员总是服务我，她很照顾我。
For dinner, Sheldon takes us to a local Outback Steakhouse. As people walk by, he provides a running commentary-- of an elderly couple--
晚餐时，谢尔顿带我们去了当地的 Outback 牛排馆。当人们走过时，他提供了即时的评论——关于一对老夫妇——
Don't get like that couple, whatever you do. It's time for the execution.
别像那对夫妇那样，不管你做什么。现在是执行时间了。
--of an overweight couple--
——关于一对超重夫妇——
Boy, are they fat. People are fat today. Woo!
天哪，他们真胖。今天的人真胖。呜！
It's as though he's sharpening his wit, readying it for the main event, teasing my dad about Canada.
就好像他在磨练自己的机智，准备为主要活动做准备，嘲笑我爸关于加拿大的事。
I don't know how you could take Canada all year around.
我不知道你怎么能一年到头待在加拿大。
You know why? Because we've got nice neighbors. It's nice. It's OK. Uh, what was I going to say?
你知道为什么吗？因为我们有好邻居。很好。没关系。呃，我要说什么来着？
You're living in the same place for how many years?
你在同一个地方住了多少年？
Oh, about-- over 35, 38 years, something like that. I'm happy here.
哦，大约——超过 35、38 年，差不多那样。我在这儿很开心。
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
For my father, I know this is a touchy subject, believing, as he always has, that Sheldon looks down on him for the dinkiness of his Canadian life and home. It's like a constant reminder of just who is second best. Later, my father will repeat Sheldon's words-- (IMITATING SHELDON) "You're still living in that same place?" He'll say, "For how many years?"
对于我父亲，我知道这是一个敏感的话题，他一直认为谢尔顿看不起他的加拿大生活和家。这就像不断提醒谁是次好的。后来，我父亲会重复谢尔顿的话——(模仿谢尔顿) “你还在住那个同样的地方？”他会说，“多少年了？”
But just then, I watch my father clench and unclench his jaw, as he does when he is brooding. I know he's trying to take the high road, trying not to ruin the evening.
但就在那时，我看着我父亲紧咬和放松下巴，就像他忧心忡忡时那样。我知道他试图走高尚路线，试图不毁掉这个晚上。
What? $200.30? Are they kidding?
什么？200.30 美元？他们在开玩笑吧？
Sheldon invites us back to his place for cookies. But my father says he isn't up for it.
谢尔顿邀请我们回他家吃饼干。但我父亲说他没心情。
Goodnight.
晚安。
[RADIO MUSIC PLAYING]
[收音机播放音乐]
It's getting cold.
天冷了。
As we walk through the restaurant parking lot to the car, my father is silent. I find myself feeling protective of him, like maybe encouraging this trip had been a bad idea, only making things worse. After midnight, lying awake in our hotel-- my father insisted we stay at one-- I lay in bed, thinking about that day in 1939, when my grandmother came back for Sheldon, not my father. For my father, not only did it push him away from Sheldon, making him feel jealous and resentful, but it also cast a shadow over the rest of his life, causing him to always feel passed over. He's mellowed with age. But as a kid, I saw it come out in all kinds of ways. Always sensitive to slights, ready for a fight at the smallest perceived offense. I wonder if there's a different way from my father to see things. If there is, the only living person in this world who can help is Sheldon. When their mom left, Sheldon was nine, my father, five. Sheldon would have understood a lot more than my father.
当我们穿过餐馆停车场走向车子时，我父亲沉默不语。我发现自己对他产生了保护欲，好像鼓励这次旅行是个坏主意，只会让事情变得更糟。午夜过后，躺在酒店里——我父亲坚持我们住在一间——我躺在床上，想着 1939 年的那一天，我祖母回来接谢尔顿，而不是我父亲。对我父亲来说，这不仅把他推离了谢尔顿，让他感到嫉妒和愤恨，而且还在他余下的生活中投下了阴影，导致他总是感到被冷落。他随年龄增长而变得温和。但小时候，我看到它以各种方式表现出来。总是对轻视敏感，为最小的感知冒犯做好战斗准备。我想知道我父亲是否有不同的方式来看待事物。如果有，世界上唯一能帮忙的活人就是谢尔顿。他们妈妈离开时，谢尔顿九岁，我父亲五岁。谢尔顿会比我父亲理解得多。
Yesterday, Buzz and Sheldon talked like a couple of kids who used to play stick ball in the old neighborhood. Today, if me and my big, fat, meddling yap have any sway, they'll have a chance to talk as men-- as brothers, even. Because if not now, when?
昨天，巴兹和谢尔顿像一对在老街区玩球的孩子一样交谈。今天，如果我和我那张大胖的管闲事的嘴有任何影响力，他们将有机会以男人——甚至兄弟——的身份交谈。因为如果不是现在，何时？
Day two.
第二天。
This is a damn good cigar.
这雪茄真不错。
He sent me--
他寄给我——
Oh, Dominican Republic? They make a damn good cigar in the Dominican Republic. What are you talking about?
哦，多米尼加共和国？他们在多米尼加共和国生产优质雪茄。你在说什么？
Despite the difficulties of last night, the coin is flipped back to the good side. Sheldon offers my father a cigar. And with a cigar, some cigar talk-- some pretty foul cigar talk.
尽管昨晚有困难，硬币又翻回了好的一面。谢尔顿给我父亲一支雪茄。随着雪茄，还有一些关于雪茄的谈话——一些相当肮脏的雪茄谈话。
We're riding on Queens Boulevard. Johnny's in the backseat with The Who. He's got his naked ass up in the air. And he's humping--
我们在皇后区大道上骑行。乔尼在后座和 The Who 在一起。他光着屁股翘在空中。他在抽动——
[LAUGH]
[笑]
Well, the funny thing is, we had to stop for a light. And there's a truck driver, sitting in the cab up high, who-- God, that was funny.
好吧，有趣的事情是，我们不得不停车等灯。有个卡车司机，坐在高高的驾驶室里，他——天哪，太搞笑了。
[LAUGH]
[笑]
Have you guys missed each other?
你们想念彼此吗？
What?
什么？
Do you miss each other?
你们想念彼此吗？
You know, he asks the weirdest questions.
你知道，他问最奇怪的问题。
[LAUGH]
[笑]
What is he, a broad?
他是什么，娘娘腔吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Eager to prove to my uncle Sheldon that in spite of the fact I'm wearing my wife's travel deodorant, I am indeed not a broad. I allow them to return to more pressing matters-- their prostates.
渴望向我叔叔谢尔顿证明，尽管我用了妻子的旅行除臭剂，但我确实不是娘娘腔。我让他们回到更紧迫的事情上——他们的前列腺。
The guy says, Jesus. He says, your prostate feels like the moon craters in there, he said. I said, thank you, doctor. He was complimenting me.
那家伙说，耶稣。他说，你的前列腺感觉像里面的月球陨石坑，他说。我说，谢谢，医生。他是在恭维我。
So if I could steer this away from the prostates-- so if my father said that it's significant it to him, to have come. What do you say?
所以如果我能把话题从前列腺上引开——如果我父亲说对他来说意义重大，能过来。你怎么说？
I agree with whatever he said.
我同意他说的一切。
But what about you?
但你呢？
I said, I agree with whatever he said. Do you want a written contract?
我说，我同意他说的一切。你想要书面合同吗？
No, I'm happy for that.
不，我很高兴。
It feels like I'm getting a taste of what growing up with Sheldon might've been like. So again, I make my move.
感觉我尝到了与谢尔顿一起长大的滋味。所以再次，我采取了行动。
So I have some questions just about-- because the stories that I know are from my father, but I'm curious what your take is, because you were older. Do you remember what was going on when your mother left, originally? Like why, and what was going on?
所以我有关于——因为我知道的故事来自我父亲，但我很好奇你的看法，因为你比较大。你记得他们母亲最初离开时发生了什么吗？比如为什么，发生了什么？
Didn't you cover this ground before yesterday?
你昨天不是已经谈过这个问题了吗？
But from my family's perspective, the way I understood it was always you were the favorite. Did you feel that way?
但从我家人的角度来看，我的理解一直是你比较受宠。你觉得那样吗？
At this point, Sheldon's face suddenly softens.
此时，谢尔顿的脸突然软化了。
I always felt that I got the short end of the stick. [LAUGH]
我一直觉得我受到了不公正待遇。[笑]
Yeah, but you were kind of a favorite with my mom.
是啊，但你跟我妈比较受宠。
Yeah, maybe with Mom because maybe temperamentally we were closer than I was with my father. My father never gave me spit. Did you ever get any money from my father?
是啊，也许跟妈妈有关，也许在性情上我们比我和我父亲更亲近。我父亲从没给我什么。你从我父亲那里得到过钱吗？
I can't remember. [INAUDIBLE].
我不记得了。[听不清]。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉声音]
You never got a dime.
你从来没得到过一分钱。
No. Can't remember. No.
不。记不得了。不。
You remember, one time I sprained my ankle so bad.
你记得，有一次我脚踝扭得那么厉害。
Oh, I'll never forget that. That was terrible.
哦，我永远不会忘记那次。那真是太糟糕了。
I laid in that bed. And he says to me, you lazy bum. Man, he went off on me that time.
我躺在那张床上。他说，你这个懒汉。天哪，那次他对我发了很大火。
Yeah. He took Sheldon once. Sheldon happened to say the word [BLEEP].
是啊。他带过谢尔顿一次。谢尔顿碰巧说了那个字 [消音]。
He came in with that [BLEEP] strap swinging, with the buckle.
他带着那条 [消音] 皮带进来了，带着扣子。
And you know, I can understand leaving a feeling level of resentment and dislike.
而且你知道，我可以理解留下一种怨恨和厌恶的感觉。
That was his way of communicating with us.
那是他与我们交流的方式。
Jesus, what a way.
天哪，什么方式。
Smack, and then--
啪，然后——
What a way.
什么方式。
Was he easier on you, do you think?
你认为他对你轻松点吗？
He wasn't that easy, but he was tough on Sheldon.
他没那么轻松，但他对谢尔顿很严厉。
I know you were closer to him than I was.
我知道你比我更亲近他。
Yeah.
是啊。
And a lot of things that went on, and you didn't understand really, what was going on.
而且很多事情发生了，你真的不明白发生了什么。
No, I did not. See, you had a different take.
不，我不明白。看，你有不同的看法。
Why, are you surprised?
为什么，你很惊讶？
But I was a kid. I didn't understand it.
但我还是个孩子。我不明白。
But you didn't know that Sheldon was getting it so bad?
但你不知道谢尔顿受了这么多罪吗？
No.
不。
In Buzz's telling, their father was always a more-or-less benign childish figure, incapable of expressing his feelings, and so given to temper tantrums. For Buzz, it was their mother who was the manipulator, the woman who played the brothers off each other. But hearing Sheldon's take, it sounds like maybe their mother didn't come to take Sheldon because she loved him best, but simply because he needed more protecting from their father.
在巴兹的叙述中，他们的父亲一直是一个或多或少无害的幼稚人物，无法表达自己的感情，所以经常发脾气。对巴兹来说，母亲才是操纵者，是那个让兄弟反目的女人。但听到谢尔顿的看法，听起来也许他们母亲不是因为最爱谢尔顿才带走他，而仅仅是因为他需要更多来自他们父亲的保护。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
For the first time during our trip, I can see my father considering Sheldon's point of view-- actually taking it in. I know it's intense for him, because he can't even meet Sheldon's eyes. Instead, he looks at me, addresses his comments to me.
在我们旅行中第一次，我可以看到我父亲在考虑谢尔顿的观点——实际上是接受它。我知道这对他是强烈的，因为他甚至无法与谢尔顿对视。相反，他看着我，对我发表评论。
You know, it's sad that my father had such a negative impact on him, you know? Just awful. Because he had so much going for him. He was a wonderful son. He worked hard. He was a good boy.
你知道，我父亲对他有这么大的负面影响真是可悲，你知道吗？真是太可怕了。因为他有那么多优点。他是个好儿子。他工作努力。他是个好男孩。
You're talking like I'm a failure in life.
你说的好像我是生活中的失败者。
No, you weren't a failure. That's the thing that I'm saying, that you weren't a failure. All I'm saying, is that emotionally, he left an impact on you.
不，你不是失败者。这就是我要说的，你不是失败者。我所说的是，在情感上，他对你留下了影响。
It took a long time for me to get out of that emotion. And now, I'm at peace with myself. I can talk about him and laugh about him. Now I want peace, quiet. I'm happy living by myself.
我花了很长时间才从那种情绪中走出来。现在，我对自己感到平静。我可以谈论他，嘲笑他。现在我想要和平、安静。我很高兴独自生活。
Are you lonely, Sheldon?
你孤独吗，谢尔顿？
No.
不。
No?
不？
The last time my father saw my grandfather in full health, my dad was visiting from Canada. My grandfather asked my father to drive him to the cemetery, to visit his parents' grave. And once there, my grandfather wept inconsolably.
我父亲最后一次看到我祖父健康的时候，是我父亲从加拿大来看望。我祖父请求我父亲开车送他去墓地，祭拜他父母的坟墓。一旦到了那里，我祖父就悲痛欲绝。
Later that day, he would succumb to a stroke, and shortly after, be moved to a nursing home. With Sheldon being more local, the burden of my grandfather's care fell mainly to Sheldon. It seems like a lot of the family's burdens fell to Sheldon.
那天晚些时候，他中风了，不久后就被送进了疗养院。由于谢尔顿更本地，照顾我祖父的重担主要落在谢尔顿身上。看起来很多家庭的负担都落在了谢尔顿身上。
They put a lot of the responsibility on him, that my dad should have been taking that responsibility. And he shouldered that.
他们把很多责任都压在他身上，我爸本该承担那些责任的。他承担了。
Who was going to take care of you? Who is going to take you to school? [INAUDIBLE]. I remember one time I was late or something. You stood outside that school. You were crying.
谁来照顾你？谁来带你去学校？[听不清]。我记得有一次我迟到了什么的。你站在学校外面。你在哭。
Screaming-- sure. I was-- yeah. Yeah.
尖叫——当然。我是——是啊。是啊。
I said, [INAUDIBLE], I'm here. I'm here.
我说，[听不清]，我在。我在。
He was good to me. A lot of times, he was good to me.
他对我很好。很多时候，他对我很好。
A lot of times I was mean to you.
很多时候我对你很刻薄。
Mean? You know, you were my older brother. You used to knock the [BLEEP] out of me sometimes. But you know, that's the way it is. We're brothers.
刻薄？你知道，你是哥哥。你有时会把我的 [消音] 给打出来。但你知道，就是这样。我们是兄弟。
Well, I was good in some ways. Some ways, I was mean.
好吧，我在某些方面很好。在某些方面，我很刻薄。
Well, who is not? Who is not? Who is not?
好吧，谁不是呢？谁不是呢？谁不是呢？
So if you feel like you were compelled to see each other now, because you knew that it's a now-or-never thing, then it means that it was important to you both, right, to see each other?
所以如果你觉得现在被迫见面，因为你知道这是现在或永远不会的事情，那么这意味着这对你们俩都很重要，对吧，见面？
You want to take that?
你想接那个吗？
Sure.
当然。
Go ahead.
继续。
It's an easy answer, yes. Yes, because we're not getting any younger. What's down the road? I'm 80, he's 85. I mean, because there was a lot of water under the bridge, and we want to close that bridge now. I want to feel easy now. I want to say, now he's going to be 86, I want to call him on his birthday and say happy birthday to him now. I'm going to stand in any [BLEEP] ceremonies anymore.
这是一个简单的答案，是的。是的，因为我们越来越老了。未来会怎样？我 80 岁，他 85 岁。我是说，因为桥下有很多水，我们现在想关闭那座桥。我现在想感到轻松。我想说，现在他要 86 岁了，我想在他的生日给他打电话祝他生日快乐。我不想再参与任何 [消音] 仪式了。
As my father speaks, as per his brother's example, dropping f-bombs like he's in it Guy Ritchie film, Sheldon keeps his arms crossed and his eyes shut tight. He's quiet for several seconds. And then he reaches out to pet his cat.
当我父亲说话时，正如他兄弟的例子，像在盖·里奇电影里一样说脏话，谢尔顿紧闭双臂，双眼紧闭。他安静了几秒钟。然后他伸出手去抚摸他的猫。
Should I leave you the cat in my will if anything happens?
如果发生什么事，我应该在遗嘱里把猫留给你吗？
If anything happens, I'll take care of the cat.
如果发生什么事，我会照顾这只猫。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I'll take care of the cat. I'm happy I came to see you. That I am.
我会照顾这只猫。我很高兴来看你。真的。
I'm happy you came. That's good, very good.
我很高兴你来了。那很好，非常好。
[STREET TRAFFIC]
[街道交通]
Well, if you want to buy a house, that one is for sale over there.
好吧，如果你想买房子，那边那栋在卖。
When it's time to leave, Sheldon walks us outside. But before we get into the rental, he points across the lawn to his neighbor's house. He tells my father that it's for sale. And then he tells him the asking price. And my father says, that doesn't sound bad at all. And Sheldon says that, what, with Canada being so bloody cold, my father should consider moving to Florida. And my father says, maybe he will.
离开的时候，谢尔顿送我们出去。但在进入租车之前，他指着草坪对面邻居的房子。他告诉我父亲它在卖。然后他告诉了他要价。我父亲说，听起来不错。谢尔顿说，加拿大这么冷，我父亲应该考虑搬到佛罗里达。我父亲说，也许会的。
All right, you take care of yourself.
好吧，照顾好自己。
Water under the bridge.
往事如烟。
Take care of yourself. You hear?
照顾好自己。你听到了吗？
Take care. You too. Safe trip, both of you's. Thank you. Thank you.
保重。你也是。祝你们俩旅行平安。谢谢。谢谢。
We'll speak. We'll speak.
我们会再联络的。我们会再联络的。
They don't get too emotional. They don't even hug goodbye. They just shake hands. And with that, it feels like Buzz has forgiven Sheldon, and Sheldon has forgiven Buzz.
他们没有表现得太感性。他们甚至没有拥抱告别。他们只是握了握手。这样，感觉巴兹原谅了谢尔顿，谢尔顿也原谅了巴兹。
Turn right on Northwest Bedford Drive.
右转上 Northwest Bedford Drive。
Oh my god, I feel so different now. You know that? I feel different, Jonny. I just feel so different. This has taken a lot off my shoulders. You know?
天哪，我现在感觉如此不同。你知道吗？我感觉不同，乔尼。我感觉如此不同。这卸下了我肩膀上很多东西。你知道吗？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Jonathan Goldstein. This story was produced by Wendy Dorr, with some help Chris Neary. If you liked that story, there is more where that came from this week. Jonathan is launching his new podcast. It is called Heavyweight, from Gimlet Media. I am super excited for this show. Jonathan used to be one of our producers here. He hosted the show Wire Tap for years. If you are ready for this to become your new favorite podcast, you can download a new episode and a longer version of this story, right now, on iTunes, or wherever it is that you get your podcasts.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦。这个故事由温迪·多尔制作，克里斯·尼里提供了一些帮助。如果你喜欢那个故事，本周还有更多类似的故事。乔纳森正在推出他的新播客。它叫《Heavyweight》，来自 Gimlet Media。我为这个节目感到超级兴奋。乔纳森曾是我们这里的制作人之一。他主持了《Wire Tap》节目多年。如果你准备好让它成为你最喜欢的播客，你可以立即在 iTunes 或任何你获取播客的地方下载新集和这个故事的加长版。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien. Our program is made by Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dan Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩制作。我们的节目由埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·蔡斯、丹·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、卡伦·达芬、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、斯蒂芬妮·福、达米安·格拉夫、查纳·乔夫·沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、美纪·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克制作。
Special thanks today to Kiku Matsuo, Yuki Zaizen, Noriko Meek, Karin Jeffrey, John Matthews, Christine Fellows, Haley Shaw, and Lawrence Tassone. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He tells everybody he knows why I'm never chosen to ask questions at the presidential debates.
今天特别感谢 Kiku Matsuo、Yuki Zaizen、Noriko Meek、Karin Jeffrey、John Matthews、Christine Fellows、Haley Shaw 和 Lawrence Tassone。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台 PRX 传递到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他告诉所有认识的人，为什么我从没被选中在总统辩论中提问。
You know, he asks the weirdest questions.
你知道，他问最奇怪的问题。
I'm Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
What is he, a broad?
他是什么，娘娘腔吗？
Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
下周回来，带上更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
(SINGING) Before I die, before I die, before I die-- Before I die, before I die, before I die. Before I go, before I go, before I die-- Before I go-- Before I die--
(歌唱) 在我死前，在我死前，在我死前——在我死前，在我死前，在我死前。在我走之前，在我走之前，在我死前——在我走之前——在我死前——